[Music]
on thursday in the midst of multiple
reports that washington quarterback alex
smith has an infection that was a result
of surgery to repair the leg that was
broken back in november washington
issued this statement on behalf of alex
smith we appreciate all the concerns and
prayers over the injury alex suffered on
november 18 against the texans although
this is a serious injury alex and his
family remain strong we would ask that
everyone please honor the smith family's
request for privacy at this time it
doesn't really confirm anything but at a
time when there are multiple reports
that there is an infection the result of
that surgery and these infections are
not uncommon i can recall rob gronkowski
the patriots tight end after he broke
his arm while
blocking
on an extra point play several years ago
he had a plate put in the arm they had
to replace the plate there was an
infection he had a picc line i mean it
was bad for him and he fought through
that over and over again after five
surgeries i think was the final total
tom brady had an infection after he had
acl repair surgery in 2008 infections do
happen we're so conditioned to think
that it's it's like taking your car in
for servicing when one of these
professional athletes especially
football players have some sort of
surgical procedure it is a serious
procedure anytime you have
your body cut open by a surgeon it is
not a good thing and there is a chance
that there could be complications so
with alex smith whatever the situation
is we wish him the best and we hope
number one he gets back to normal and
then number two that we see him back on
a football field but some of the reports
have characterized the condition as
potentially career ending and it really
wouldn't be a shock when you consider
the gravity of the injury joe theismann
never played again after suffering the
compound fracture in his lower leg in
1985 and there is a chance that alex
smith may not return and he's got a lot
of football left if he's able to play
he's still only 34 years old so we wish
him all the best number one for his
health for his long-term well-being but
also so he can continue his football
career if that's what he truly wants to
do as washington moves forward now
without alex smith without colt mccoy
and it's mark sanchez and josh johnson
the rest of the way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports